hair grows faster when you constantly
cut it
myth you have dandruff because your
scalp
is dry dandruff isn't a dry scalp
problem it's actually almost always oily
shampooing causes extra hair loss myth
hi i'm annabelle kingsley i'm consultant
psychologist and brand president at
philip kingsley and a trichologist is a
scientist of the hair and scalp hi i'm
dr howard i'm a new york-based
board-certified dermatologist and the
founder of girl and hair dermatology is
the study of the skin
scalp hair and mucous membranes and
today we will be debunking myths about
hair hair grows faster when you
constantly cut it
myth hair grows around half an inch a
month and cutting it won't speed up that
process
on average we have around 120
000 hair follicles on our scalp and
they're all going through different
phases of the hair growth cycle right
correct so there's anagen catagen
telogen and oxygen and right now on your
scalp generally up to 90 of hairs will
be in the growth phase and then the rest
are waiting to fall out and then some
are shedding so hair is not going to
grow faster if you cut it
but it will look nice if you get your
trims regularly you have dandruff
because your scalp
is dry dandruff isn't a dry scalp
problem it's actually almost always oily
dandruff is also known as seborrheic
dermatitis an overgrowth of naturally
occurring yeast on your scalp called the
malassezia yeast
and they are lipophilic which means they
love oil
yes they gobble it up and the more oils
on your scalp the harder they are the
happier they are the more flakes you
tend to see yes you might find it's
behind your ears on the side of your
nose eyebrows
so it can be right here even yeah
wherever the yeast likes the sebum some
things to treat dandruff are targeted
shampoos scalp toners
scalp masks and also look at what you're
eating
washing your hair every day is bad for
you it's a myth but there is some fact
in there you want to treat your scalp
just as you treat your skin so you want
to make sure it's properly cleansed
you want to make sure you have good
hydration on the scalp if you are a very
active person maybe you want to cleanse
some more fine hair like mine if i don't
shampoo daily my roots get very greasy
and flat and the reason for this is that
when you have fine hair you have more
hairs on your scalp and therefore you
have more oil glands on your scalp
because every hair
is attached to an oil gland whereas
coarser hair textures sometimes you know
the sebum has a hard time leaving
the scalp to the tip of the hair and
it's counterintuitive because you think
that maybe coily hair or textured hair
you don't want to wash it a lot but
actually the washing process is a part
of the hydration process so the more you
wash the more you hydrate shaving causes
hair to grow back thicker and darker
so hair naturally grows tapered so when
you shave you just make the ends
blunt and you're cutting the hair at a
thicker point along the hair shaft so
shaving may appear to make your hair
grow thicker and darker but it actually
doesn't if you were wax you're taking
the hair out of the foam out of the
follicle so it's still going to grow
back tapered if shaving did make our
hair grow back thicker i'd shave my hair
air drying your hair is better than blow
drying it depends on your method again
so
if you are air drying but your method of
air drying is
really scrunching or constantly tugging
and
you know yeah that's going to be more
damaging well you know what i know some
people who like air dry but they're like
running out of the house and they'll
swoop their hair in a ponytail but it's
like wet in the middle but dry on the
outside that could be a problem with
that wet hair all the time in the middle
or at the base of your scalp yeah so if
you just brush your hair gently and let
it dry without really
touching it much without roughly towel
drying it
that's fine but equally blow drying
doesn't have to be damaging if you do it
properly in the right way and using a
heat protectant
great
you should hold it at least six inches
away like around this far away you can
start on a medium heat setting and then
reduce to low as you go you use the back
of your hand
as a reference if it feels too hot
it's too hot for your hair especially
with curly or coily or zigzag pattern
hair a hooded dryer may be
a good choice if you like to wear wigs
weaves box braids and sometimes air
drying it might not be the best option
because you can get mold and mildew
within the braids if it's not dry
properly one isn't necessarily better
than the other all method dependent
shampooing causes extra hair loss myth
this is something that i hear all the
time what shampooing does is it simply
dislodges hairs that were sitting
loosely in their hair follicle and were
ready to come out so you're not actually
causing hair loss it's normal to lose up
to 100 hairs a day but i really do
encourage my clients who are
experiencing excessive deadly hair
shedding to shampoo regularly because
it's really important in terms of
keeping your scalp healthy and the
healthier your scalp is the better able
it is to support new 100 agree focus on
your scalp when you shampoo and just the
suds that run down through the lengths
of your hair will be enough to cleanse
them only shaving causes ingrown hairs
myth
waxing can cause ingrown hairs with any
hair removal method if you break the
hair instead of pulling it out right
from the root you're more likely to get
an ingrown hair because the end will be
blunt as opposed to tapered it's all
about like when you cut the hair the
angle in which you're cutting it goes
back into the skin so you have a curling
but what happens when that curling
occurs there is an inflammatory response
that happens with that curling so that's
where you get the red bump and sometimes
that red bump can become a pus fill bump
and you can have a real situation there
perhaps shaving after shower i'm using a
blade designated for sensitive skin
could be helpful or a fresh sharp blade
yes and also exfoliation so gentle
exfoliation you know maybe once twice a
week yes absolutely stress makes you
have gray hair well there are elements
of truth and myth to this so when you go
gray is largely dependent on genes so if
your mother or your father went gray
early it does increase the chances that
you will too but stress can certainly
speed up the process your hair's color
is determined by something called
melanin which is pigment
and the color of your hair ranging from
blonde hair which will have less melanin
to darker hair which will have
a lot more melanin when your
hair bulb stops producing these pigment
cells is when you start to turn gray i
think embracing the grays totally um it
can look beautiful or you can color over
them whatever works for you if you pluck
a gray hair
two more will grow in its place
myth what i find happens is that when
you notice one gray hair
you go searching for others so maybe
you're just looking more as you're
saying yeah so you start like a private
eye yeah and you find them everywhere
there's a strand screw tonight you're
saying it's all in your mind there is no
data that shows that if you pluck a gray
hair you have two yeah sprout up this
myth is really common but
i just think maybe it's it's a word of
caution because
you shouldn't pluck gray hairs out
because over time if you continuously
pull a hair out of its follicle you can
damage the hair follicles you don't want
to damage your no we love them so much
and you think well one isn't going to
make a difference but when one turns
into 30 and you're constantly plucking
30 or more then you can get you know
patches of hair loss on your skin that's
never good no you can repair a split end
myth once it's split that's it it's
split yeah
nice
thanks split ends happen because of
general day-to-day weathering so blow
drying brushing
towel drying it roughly wind exposure
uv exposure holy hat that you bought
that you think is so cool that you want
to wear all winter so hair doesn't
regenerate itself treat your hair like
your favorite cashmere sweater yes but
if you want to cure for a split and you
have to
cut it baldness is only passed down
through your mother losing your hair has
some genetic components but it's not
only because mom lost her hair the
boldness gene could be passed from your
mother's side it could be passed from
your father's side it could even be
inherited from a grandparent or a
great-grandparent there are many
different types of hair loss so
hereditary hair loss
or boldness which i i don't really like
it's called androgenic alopecia or
reduced hair volume so androgenic
alopecia is a genetic type of hair loss
that can be inherited from either your
mother or your father's side but it's
also dependent on your hormone levels
specifically your
androgens so anything that impacts your
hormone levels can then impact
your hair so it can potentially make
density changes worse so things like
polycystic ovary syndrome
menopause oral contraceptives puberty
pregnancy so the best thing is to speak
to a trichologist or a dermatologist so
that they can speak to you about all the
different options that are available the
more you brush your hair the healthier
it will be so brushing or over brushing
can actually cause micro tears along the
hair shaft and be potentially bad for
your hair especially when it comes to
textured coily or zigzag pattern hair
and there's actually something where
there's finger detangling in the coily
or natural hair community where you use
your fingers to detangle your hair so
you should detangle your hair
regularly just so that those tangles
don't accumulate and mat together look
for a brush with rounded plastic prongs
so these aren't going to scratch your
hair or your scalp and a vented cushion
base do the back of hand test so gently
run your brush over the back of your
hand if it leaves red marks if if it
feels harsh or scratchy it's going to be
damaging your hair for curly or textured
hair there are actually two brushes that
i really love one is called the felicia
leatherwood
brush it has openings so when you brush
coily hair the brush actually expands
it's like a spring and then there's
another one called the cosmology brush
they have really big
teeth you know so you can definitely get
it through really coarse and thick hair
oils will make hair grow faster and
longer oh this is a good one
no
oh i cannot stand when i see magic
growth oils jordan rip that one up
oils do not make your hair grow faster
and longer but eating enough oils in
your diet
important to scalp yes so rather than
you know putting olive oil on your scalp
put on your salad i have to tell you
about what's going on in the curly
community there's a whole big discussion
about no oil so there's some stylists
who said absolutely no oils on the hair
i never really suggest applying pure oil
to your hair but using a cream it
contains things like olive oil or castor
oil or coconut oil those can be really
beneficial to
the
aesthetic appearance of your hair wigs
weaves and braids always protect your
hair
myth not all the time i sometimes wear
my hair out naturally sometimes i put it
in a bun sometimes i wear box braids
sometimes i wear a wig or weave it all
depends on my mousse so it's a part of
just changing hairstyles but in that
with curly textured hair
you can experience some hair loss with
the frequent changing some people use
protective styling as a way to minimize
the manipulation
on their hair but if it's too heavy if
it's in too long if you neglect your
scalp while you have your weave or if
your wig braids are too tight you're
putting too much traction on your hair
follicle or your hair it can cause
breakage exactly exactly i like to call
it responsible protective styling you
know not only relying on one style for
too long so letting your
hair
breathe and just wearing your hair as is
you should not neglect your scalp you
should be cleansing you should be
hydrating finding someone who really
understands responsible protective
styling so if you're going to a salon
and making sure he or she understands
that tight is never good
tenderness is never good because it
hurts if it hurts it's never good
tenderheaded is just that
myth and it's a phrase that we hear all
the time right if you say ouch you know
you might get a little pang of the comb
to be still and you hear phrases like
tenderheaded when you're super small so
you grow up thinking it's just a part of
life that you're just sensitive in
certain areas because you've always been
told that you're sensitive in those
areas and while that may be true for
some people as far as just like scalp
sensitivity for many people actually the
tenderheadedness could mean something
else there could be inflammation there
on a microscopic level that if we catch
early especially scarring alopecia it
can do good tenderness isn't necessarily
normal and you don't want to dismiss it
never suffer in silence and be really
discerning when it comes to choosing
your products if you're experiencing
hair loss or a scalp concerned you can
either see a trichologist or
a dermatologist or even a really
experienced stylist who's all about
education hair education can take you a
long way